[Music]
date of birth
friday 31st of december 1937.
you're living with your daughter at the
moment yes until she goes to live in
paris
no dad why'd you keep going on about
paris you told me no i didn't
i'm sorry and you told me the other day
have you forgotten she's forgotten
paris they don't even speak english
there
[Music]
dad i'd like you to meet laura how do i
say you're gorgeous
thank you i must say he's charming yeah
not always laura has come around to help
you i don't need her or anyone else i
can manage
very well on my own everything all right
who are you actually it's me paul oh
i live here what is this nonsense and
it's me ah there's yours your father
seemed a bit confused
something wrong where's anne sorry ma'am
where is she i'm here
what's the matter dad strange things
going on around us
don't worry everything will sort itself
out
saw it in his eyes didn't know who i was
it was like i was a stranger to him
just did something to me i don't know
what she's cooking up against me but
she's cooking something up what are you
talking about dad
i'm not leaving my flat i am not
leaving my flat this really is my flat
isn't it
[Music]
you see the situation is very simple my
daughter is of the opinion that i cannot
manage on my own
i'm so sorry about this why she
understands
perfectly
[Music]
it's important i explained it all to you
why do you keep looking as if there's
something wrong everything is fine
i think she tries to do the best she can
for you anthony everything will be all
right i promise you
there's something funny going on
[Music]
you